jeudi vendredi après émission ouais et
après le 22 fait une pause jusqu'au 8
janvier ça veut dire chacun fait sa vie
le premier qui m'appelle je viens chez
lui je nique ça
race ok non non non je vous dis les gars
de semaines de vacances c'est énorme on
va se manquer vous allez nous manquer
franchement qu'est-ce que tu as prévu de
faire toi rien du
tout c'est un peu l'histoire de ta vie
non mais je vais faire des beau cadeaux
qu'est-ce tu vas faire toi moi je vais
une semaine chez ma maman à Biaritz et
après une semaine à Marrakech avec ma
chérie ah cool génial pas mal vous une
semaine à Paris et une semaine avec mon
amoureux en Espagne non fort et toi je
vais à Rio au brés ah oui c'est vrai ton
amoureux pas que oua mon amoureux et
puis des amis avecan également comment
avec avec toi tu ve non je suis j'ai
déjà des projets vous moi je vais aller
voir ma famille en Pologne pas mal oui
Pologne ah ou et au nouvel an je vais
aller à Miami Dubaï je sais pas ouais
cool ah ouais ça c'est banal ouis ça
c'est normal moi la Pologne la polne je
me rappelle que j'avais été à Budapest
ah
ou quelle belle villeouou quelle belle
ville c'est quoi la capitaine de la
polonne euh Varsovie bravo bah elle est
polonaise
oua et alors moi je suis tunisien je
connais pas la capitale de la Tunisie ah
non c'est vrai c'est bien là-bas je suis
jamais allé tu es jamais allé non je
peux t'inviter tu parles ma famille non
c'est vrai oui je parle polonais mais je
pas non plus comment on dit je te bouffe
le cul un
peu non mais les gars gar mais on arrête
de petites secondes là s déconner non
mais dans quelle émission il y a un gars
qui vient pas il vient pas hyper souvent
en plus il vient deux fois par semaine
il y a un gars première intervention de
l'émission dans quellemission Mme dis
dit ça chez Laurent r sur BFM non mais
il est fou ce qu' là mais c'est un fou
ce
mec comment ça c
traduction c'est quoi
çaéquipe c'est quoi ça sortez les deux
là sortez plus vous voir non mais c'est
quoi cette équipe là sans déconner
l'autre il prend l'autre il prend
des r peut-être une polonaise un jour po
qu'est-ce qu'ils sont cons sans rigoler
vous allez faire quoi vous moi je vais
aller dans mon périgor natal ouais alors
je ouais je sais c'est pas ouf mais
j'adore non non je t'explique rig c'est
génial on rend l'antenne à 46 surou sais
je me su fait pas 49 ouais je sais je me
suis fait engueuler par qui par toi par
vous et dans en régie j'appelle j'ai dit
les gars PAF j'ai dit c'est 46 pour Land
il m'ont dit non ils ont dit qui
il mais qui il je veux savoir qui est il
mais ils ont dit mais qui j'ai dit qui
je veux les noms ben comment on dit
ils
ontou pas non mais alors alors polonne
vousou non mais c'est c'est bien la il
fait froid en polne nonè froid non SC
moi ça laassera la Pologne j' dir jamais
non mais j'ai rien contre vous ni contre
votre famille mais j'iris pas en polne
mais si viens non non franchement je
avoir froid et tout non mais je suis un
enfant du Sud moi non non non non
franchement là on va te réchauffer non
non mais non mais t'emmerde pas non non
mais je vais pas aller je vais rester
sur Paname
Mo pas avec S toi tu vas où toi moi je
fais Noël en famille à Vernon dans le 27
et après du CAM toi au niveau de la
dépression tu es comment là sur
l'échelle de Richter non mais sans
déconner tu es comment c'est vachement
bien tu fais quoi tu fais quoi je fais
Noël en famille dans le 27 à Vernon et
après un petit peu de boulot pe pe de
travail première semaine à Paris et
peut-être un peu d'Italie en deè semaine
waouh Italie j'adore
une le sud ton mec ouais mon
mec j'adore s déconner TUC ton mec là
tranquille quoi elle a des étoiles dans
les yeux qu'est-ce çaas toi tu pleures
en fait je me suis fait des des ongles
super pointus je me suis mis les ongles
dans
[Rires]
les e ouais le talent c'est
magique franchement par contre fais
gaffe fais pas un faux mouement parce
que tu restes sur de lui crever une cou
[__] ça te va bien c'est joli ça te va
bien ces ongles ah merci mais c'est
dangereux les ongles longs c'est
exceptionnel c'est beau moi j'avais même
envie de les faire tu sais comme ça
regarde regarde comm enir au main
d'argent tu sais comm tu vois bon et toi
tu pars où toi moi je vais à Strasbourg
VO ma famille ouais et bouff-moi le C en
alsacien c'est le Morche
ok je peux plus vousbl euh euh et vous
êtes à Paris pendant non non Mo moi je
alors moi moi je on est on est avec SEP
copains on part avec sept copains on
part d'abord dans le sud ok euh et après
on prend l'avion et on part à Marbella
pour nouvel an ou euh pour le nouvel an
à Marbella on est exc vous prenez
l'avion c'est-à-dire quelle compagnie ça
se passe comment
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la non on part d'abord sur le sud pour
faire un point un point voilà avec pour
préparer la deuxè semaine non non voilà
après je la même bande part ensuite aprè
on part toutous ça re garçons ah on est
que des garçons 7 garçons joua on est h
en fait on est h en tout non vous aviez
dit 7 ça qui jou qui jouera le rôle de
blanchenige du
coup BL 7 est h ah bah ou changé préparé
ma blague à blague
[Applaudissements]
est et et ceux qui veulent venir avec
moi sont les
bienvenus allez
euh non mais c'est que des sportifs
frère
Tuch ah c'est on fait non on fait muscu
le matin padle après un truc c'est
vraiment on fait tu vois on est 7 on est
on est h en fait en VI quatre chambres
de de c'est très très sportif il y a que
des c'est que des
c'est que des top 100 voilà c'est la il
va passer de TR jours il va passer de TR
jours en
entraîneur quand il passe qu' a toute la
bande qu' connait la bande qui je parle
et donc lui il AR il met un
surbêement il est toute l' des jours en
surbêtement dans la maison frère et nous
on s'entraîne et des fois on le voit il
prend un ballon il fait
ça je vous jure que c'est vrai il se
fait des tacles à lui-même je le vois
sauter dans la peleis frère mais
qu'est-ce qu'il fait qu'est- qu'il
fait il va passer il va mais
là
a lu faudrait
de trop de retard c'est relou il il va
ralentir le groupe donc non mais c'est
vrai c'est chiant l'enjeu pour vous
alors d'être encore non non on va kiffer
aussi on Marbella sympathique voilà on
va kiffer tu l'impression que tu as
envie de venir avec nous bah franchement
ça me chauffe parce que muscu tous les
matins c'est c'est ma c'est mie et voilà
bien entre couill qui est chaud qui est
chaud qui qui s'est chauffé sur mon plan
franchement hommes qui peuvent venir
mais les femmes on peut pas si bien sûr
sûr
allez et vos amis sont beau gosses ah
ouais ouais ouais ah c'est tous des
sportifs ou corps musclé PEC saillant ah
ouis abdos dessiné et couill
descendu non non non non mais non mais
ils sont et pour la plupart ils sont ils
sont maqué oh tout est détournable ah
ouais non il sonf non 4/ H8 ouais ah bah
c'est la moitié quoi moié donc voilà on
est quatre célibataires et quatre quatre
en couple ok ok voilà donc voilàah si
vous voulez venir bah vous voulez venir
à vous bah ouais suis à [__] avec nous
ben je sais pas du sport non mais tu es
pas avec a toi he si mais je peux venir
comme ça de jours venir de TR jours tu
vas te faire chbron par les copains et
ou
non mais quoi attends e oh non tu veux
venir sur OK mais non mais non tu vois
pas ah si je l'ai déjà fait he prendre
l'avion en 24 heur V voir fait qu'elle a
fait ça qu-ce qu'elle a celle bah c'est
vrai vous la vérité tu veux pas partir
en Pologne plutôt avec je partir en
Pologne avec Polska c'est quoi ton vrai
ah oui je sais ah non je l'ai secret ah
je le dirai jamais non d'accord il y a
des secrets ici maintenant comment elle
va comment elle va
edvig
edvig non non je dirai jamais son vrai
prénom c'est secret secret secret secret
mais tu sais que personne n'a sais que
c'est tous des faux prénoms ici autour
de la bien sûr Jean-Michel pas son vrai
prénom il s'appelle Gustave gust rigol
pour tu as chisi JeanMichel c'est nul
benim c'est bar en
fait s'appelle Barla je te jure que
c'est vrai lui il s'appelle Pedro en
vrairo je te jure tu savais tu savais ou
pas qu'on avait
changé il s'appelle
fber ça ça bien je te jure et elle
Pascale de la tour duupin s'appelle
Yasmina ah ouais
ent pas une
arabe mais ça veut rien dire euh
qu'est-ce que tu veux dire par là euh tu
vois oui lui c s'appelle Cyr en vrai
pour de vraiou m'app
cy cy ah bah oui logique ouais tu as
compris et Géraldine Josian Josian ou la
copine elle é direct elle s'appelle même
pas ma sais comment elle s'appelle ang
Josian
[Rires]
de
oui c'est
Mamadou c'est pas
Casimir tu sors des vannes de merde
[Applaudissements]
je et comment il va comment il va mon
petit
archibalde mon petit archi allez on va
se retrouver dans un instant il y a La
Dépêche d'Andre qui arrive tout le monde
va bien vous êtes en forme ah ouais vous
êtes content vous êtes content que ce
soit bientôt les vacances moi je déteste
plus être à manquer parce qu' après je
fais en fait quand quand je suis
plusantenne je comme j'ai un trop plein
d'énergie met obligé d'insulter des gens
Aué à tout de
suite